>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN WANTS
TO GET TOUGH ON CRIME BUT HE
MIGHT WANT TO TALK TO HIS
VICE PRESIDENT.
THE MINNESOTA BAIL FUND PROMOTED
BY KAMALA HARRIS DURING THE
GEORGE FLOYD RELATED RIOTS OF
2020, RECENTLY HELPED SECURE THE
RELEASE OF A REPEAT FELON WHO
GOT CHARGED WITH MURDER.
SEAN MICHAEL TILLMAN SHOT AND
KILLED A PASSENGER ON A TRAIN
PLATFORM AFTER REPORTEDLY BEING
RELEASED FROM JAIL THREE WEEKS
PRIOR.
ALL THANKS TO THE MINNESOTA
FREEDOM FUND.
THE SAME GROUP HERE IS PROMOTED
WITH THIS TWEET.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO COME A CHIP
AND NOW TO HELP POST BAIL FOR
THOSE PROTESTING ON THE GROUND
IN MINNESOTA.
THANKS TO HARRIS' PROMOTION, THE
GROUP REPORTEDLY RAISED
$35 MILLION IN A FEW WEEKS.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST PERSON TO
COMMIT MURDER AFTER BEING BAILED
OUT BY THE FREEDOM FUND.
REMEMBER THIS?
JUNE 2020?
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING WHEN YOU
COMPARE THESE RIOTS TO
JANUARY 6TH BECAUSE THE RIOTS
WERE THIS ONGOING TERRIFYING
NIGHT PURGE.
IT SICKENED YOU AND THOUGHT THE
COUNTRY WAS OVER.
IT DIDN'T END.
THE SCARY THING IS PEOPLE WOULD
NOT TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU WOULD SAY WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THEY GO NO, NO, SOCIAL
JUSTICE OR JUST LAUGH.
MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
JANUARY 6TH, ABOMINABLE RIOTS.
BUT SO ON OF THE ORDINARY AND SO
ON IN SUCH A ONE OFF THAT EVERY
ONE CONDEMNED IT.
THE MEDIA COVER THE CONSISTENTLY
NIGHTLY VIOLENCE IS PREFERABLE
BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON WHO'S
DOING IT.
THERE'S RED HACKS THEY ARE AND
THEY'LL TAKE THAT DAY AS FAR
WORSE BUT THIS IS WHEN YOU
REALIZE THE VIRTUE SIGNALING HAS
A BODY COUNT.
IF PUT A STICKER ON YOUR CAR
THAT SAYS BLM, THAT'S FINE, BUT
THE FREE KILLERS AND SO YOU CAN
FEEL ENLIGHTENED, THAT'S GOING
TO CAUSE PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE TO DROP THE FREE FELONS
OFTEN END OF THE HOUSES OF THE
PEOPLE WHO FREED THEM.
IF YOU OBJECT TO THAT, ASK
YOURSELF WHY DO YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT?
WE HAVE THE LIVE WITHOUT.
>> Dana: AS A JUDGE AND A CASE
HE WOULD HAVE WORKED ON, YOU
MIGHT HAVE BEEN FURIOUS?
>> Judge Jeanine: YES
>> Judge Jeanine: YES.
>> Dana: TELL ME MORE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M ON
WEILAND, BUT SHE TWEETED IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO CHIP IN THE
MINNESOTA IMPROVEMENT FUND TO
HELP THOSE WITH TESTING ON THE
GROUND, LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THE
DIRTBAG WAS DOING.
HE WAS INDECENTLY EXPOSING
HIMSELF AND HE WAS IN FRONT OF A
WOMAN.
THAT'S NOT A GUY WHO WAS
PROTESTING ON THE GROUND.
SHE WANTED HIM FOR YOU, AND HE
KILLED SOMEONE.
IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY, PEOPLE
FREED WITH NO BAIL OR BEING
FREED EVEN THOUGH THEY HAD GUNS
AND CAN GO OUT AND GET ANOTHER
GUN AND KILL SOMEBODY.
WHERE THE GUY WHO DID A SUCKER
PUNCH THE LEVEL THREE
SEX OFFENDER WHO TOOK IT DOWN
FROM ATTEMPTED MURDER TO A
MISDEMEANOR.
THE WHOLE CONCEPT AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT'S GOING ON IS THAT WE ARE
MINIMIZING THE VICTIM AND WE ARE
CELEBRITY RISING AND PUFFING UP
THE CRIMINAL SAYING WE HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM TO CODDLE THE
CRIMINALS AND IGNORE THE
VICTIMS.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
THAT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
IT JUST IS AND THEIR POLICIES.
>> Dana: THE MINNESOTA FREEDOM
FUND SAID IT WAS ONLY $2,000
THAT THEY DONATED WHICH THEY SAY
IS A SMALL AMOUNT COMPARED TO
THE AVERAGE BAIL REQUEST OF MORE
THAN 8000-$15,000.
THE POST RELEASE TEAM ATTEMPTED
TO CONTACT HIM AS THEY DO WITH
THE CLIENTS UPON RELEASE.
IF BUT IT DIDN'T SEEM TO WORK
THIS TIME.
>> Brian: LOOK, THIS IS A
HORRIBLE CASE AND I CANNOT
IMAGINE FOR THE LIFE OF ANYTHING
THAT VICE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
YOU SAY PEACEFUL PROTEST AND, I
DON'T THINK YOU BLAME
DEMOCRATS --
>> Judge Jeanine: LOOK AT THE
CRIME AND THE DEMOCRATS.
A >> Harold: I GET IT, I DON'T
BLAME KAMALA HARRIS AND I AGREE
WITH YOU WHOLEHEARTEDLY, FAIR, I
AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY IS THAT WE
NEED TO BE TOUGHER ON CRIME AND
WE NEED TO KEEP THOSE BEHIND
BARS WHO ARE COMMITTING VIOLENT
ACTS.
BUT TO BLAME KAMALA HARRIS FOR
THIS IS SLIGHTLY UNFAIR.
>> Dana: PERSONALLY NOT TO
BLAME COME UP THE SENTIMENT OF
RELEASING FELONS AND I KNOW YOU
SAID YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH SIMPLY
FOR THE OLDER FELONS.
>> Harold: A CALL
>> Brian: HADTHE REPUTATION EARA
SUDDEN SAYS I FEEL THAT FOR THE
CRIMINALS AND FIND A WAY TO GETT
CRAZY.
THE NUMBERS ARE CROSS HAS BEEN
UNDENIABLE HOW THE MOST
EXPERIENCE -- EVERYBODY EXCEPT
ME AND GREG.
BUT THE NUMBERS MUST BE HORRIFIC
FOR THE PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES TO BE A LONDON
ORDER PRESENT AT PRESIDENT ALL
OF A SUDDEN.
NOT JUST THE SQUAD, THEY HAVE
IGNORED AND NOT SMOKE AND THAT
WHEN IT'S TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
AS CORI BUSH, SHE WANTS TO
DEFUND THE POLICE AND YOU CAN
SAY THAT YOU WANT TO CRACK DOWN
WHEN THE WHOLE HISTORY AS YOU
SAID NOTHING DURING THE RIOTS.
THE CITY WAS ABANDONED BECAUSE
THE PANDEMIC WRECKED LIVELIHOODS
AND DESTROYED AND THE CITY
BLOCK.
I THINK THE POINTS BETWEEN LAW
AND ORDER IS LIKE 15 POINTS FOR
DEMOCRATS ON THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO CLOSE THE GAP OR HE'S GOING
TO GET SLAMMED ON ELECTION DAY.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE HAVE
SHORT-TERM MEMORY LOSS, I THINK
PEOPLE REALLY MEMBER THE PARTY
OF LAW AND ORDER.
THE PRESIDENT GOING CRAZY, HE
WANTED TO USE SPECIAL FORCES TO
GO OUT THERE AND GRAB STREETS
BACK.
YOU CANNOT SAY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WAS SLEEPING
AT THE SWITCH AND HE'S
DESPERATELY TRYING TO GET THE
MAYORS TO CRACK DOWN ON